dans une petite salle du musée des
beaux-arts de montréal une séance photos
plutôt originale les uns après les
autres
une centaine de montréalais passe devant
l'objectif d'angelica das depuis 2012
cette photographe brésilienne parcourt
le monde pour faire le portrait de
citoyens de tout âge et de toutes
origines
puis associé la couleur de leur peau à
une des couleurs du nuancier du
fabricant peinture pantone un projet
baptisé une monnaie mondiale buvette sur
place
montréal c'est spécial parce qu'on peut
y voir toutes les couleurs de notre
planète dans une seule ville one
sellette
angelica a déjà pris en photo plus de
4000 personnes dans 30 villes de 18 pays
sur tous les continents
ayers dix palettes je me sers de cette
palette parce que je connais le numéro
pour le noir et je connais le numéro
pour le blanc et je peux vous assurer
que sur les 4000 personnes que j'ai
prise en photo aucune ne correspond à
ces deux couleurs
donc la question est pourquoi est ce que
l'on continue à définir la race humaine
selon les critères de noir et de blanc
angelica né à rio dé janeiro a eu l'idée
de ce projet en réalisant la variété des
couleurs de peau au sein de sa propre
famille
la mosaïque de visages humains qu'elle a
créée au fil des années en les associant
au nuancier pantone est tout à fait
saisissante fascinant également de
constater que des personnes aux origines
différentes ont la même couleur du
nuancier une remarquable palette de
couleurs de peau pour ouvrir le dialogue
sur la diversité du genre humain
l'objectif de ce travail
ce n'est pas juste de collectionner des
photos mais de créer un dialogue et ce
message de diversité angelica lui
transmet aussi dans des écoles un peu
partout dans le monde en donnant des
ateliers dans lesquels les jeunes
dessinent leur autoportrait
sur le même principe que ces photos le
musée des beaux-arts de montréal qui a
invité la photographe va présenter des
portraits des montréalais dans un projet
spécial l'automne prochain de son côté
angélique hadas va continuer à arpenter
notre planète pour compléter sa mosaïque
ici catherine françois radio canada
montréal
[Musique]